ils patrouillent en terrain conquis
après des semaines de combats les russes
ont pris la ville de vol n'aura va situé
sur la route reliant mario paul à
donetsk l'armée russe poursuit son
mouvement pour conquérir tout l'est du
pays
l'ennemi a terminé la phase de mouvement
et de regroupement de ses unités et les
a déplacés vers le territoire des
régions de donetsk de lougansk
nous croyons que des combats intenses se
tiendront dans ces territoires dans un
futur proche
selon le pentagone l'armée russe se
renforce au nord 18 mai au sud-ouest de
donetsk avec des chars des bataillons de
soutien et de l'artillerie l'aéroport
denis proulx lui a été détruit le
kremlin prévient même en cas de
pourparlers cette offensive vers l'est
ne s'arrêtera pas au cours du premier
cycle de négociations le président
vladimir poutine a ordonné de suspendre
l'opération militaire spéciale après
avoir acquis la conviction que les
ukrainiens n'avaient pas l'intention de
faire pareil il a été décidé qu'au cours
des prochains cycles de discussions il
n'y aurait pas de pause tant qu'un
accord final ne seraient pas atteints et
signer
la ville de cramât torse qu déserté
vielles au son des sirènes avertissant
des raids aériens mais certains
habitants refusent de fuir
je ne laisserai pas la ville se rendre
je suis né dans la ville je ne laisserai
pas tomber
je vais les combattre avec mes béquilles
selon des analystes vladimir poutine
chercherait une victoire rapide dans le
donbass avant le défilé militaire du 9
mai à moscou qui marque la victoire des
soviétiques sur l'allemagne nazie